[Music]
Hollywood movies have envisaged a future
of hoverboards and flying cars these
imaginary machines might not be too far
from reality by 2030 a quarter of shared
passenger miles traveled on America's
roads could be in self-driving vehicles
it's believed eight out of ten people
will be using Robo taxis and cities were
available by 2035 there will also be
more emphasis on sharing journeys all
this could reduce the number of cars on
city streets by 60 percent emissions by
80 percent and road accidents by 90
percent and then there are flying cars
or more accurately passenger drones and
helicopter hybrids uber is investing
heavily in this technology Los Angeles
Dallas and some states in Australia
could see test flights within a couple
of years but these cross city flights
will require changes to air traffic
control systems which will probably take
longer to develop than the flying
vehicles themselves traveling across
country could be far quicker - China is
leading the world in high-speed bullet
trains that are capable of traveling
over 400 kilometres per hour by 2020
80 percent of the country's major cities
could be linked to the network
but for high-speed travel the ambitious
Hyperloop could leave bullet trains in
the dust it's an ambitious system in
which pods move along tubes in a mere
vacuum the lack of air resistance means
paas could reach speeds of over 1,000
kilometers per hour
Virgen wants to deliver a fully
operational Hyperloop system by the
mid-2020s the company claims its
Hyperloop pods could travel from Los
Angeles to Las Vegas in 30 minutes but
the potential dangers of travel at such
great speeds and the cost mean the
Hyperloop will not be a reality for
decades in the air the makers of
supersonic jets are promising to slash
travel times to arian wants to carry 12
passengers in luxury at 1.4 times the
speed of sound
about 60% faster than typical aircraft
today and rival boom hopes to be flying
its supersonic airliner by 2023 carrying
55 passengers up to 2.2 times is the
[ __ ]
skeptics say these ideas are impractical
and expensive with many technical
challenges to overcome
despite this tech and engineering
companies are boldly taking up the
challenges of passenger transit
promising to propel us into the future
[Music]
you